[Music]
meredith is in tampa florida hi meredith
how are you
hey i'm doing all right how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so found out last night that my rent is
going to be increasing by 62 percent
once my lease is up from good lord 50
yeah to 1700 a month so i'm i'm
currently working the baby steps on baby
step two
and i wouldn't be house poor per se i
would still have a little bit but my
shovel would be drastically dented
that's pretty
amazing yeah so you're paying a lot like
1100 now
yeah 100 now were you under you think
you were under the market before or the
market has just jumped that much
i think maybe a little bit of both um
honestly i feel like like i've looked
around since then and it looks like
everything in this area like people are
just flooding to florida and so i think
i think it's just driving up and most
things are comparable to the 1700 amount
that's coming around so
so you either move down in quality of
house or location
or you accept the increase
basically yeah and a lot of the
apartment complexes around here are
income restricted so it's too much to
move there
but also we'll be pretty strapped here
so wanted to get your input would you
sign the lease given the way the housing
market is uh the only thing i would
wonder the caveat to that is if i don't
sign the lease and i go month to month
it's a 100 difference which i feel like
is pretty low
for not signing the lease so i don't
know if it seems like maybe it would be
best to hold off pay the extra hundred
dollars a month and if it seems like the
market's going to go out what's your
household in
70 000.
wow is it a one bedroom and are you
living alone
so it's a two-bedroom and i have been
looking for a roommate because i'm
trying to really go cheetah intense and
all that fun stuff for baby step two um
which would have been great before but
now almost feels like
it's more than breaking even but it kind
of feels like it's a lot less pumps if i
were to get a roommate but how much
longer do you have with that with this
baby step two with this increased rent
how much longer do you think it will
take
with the increased rent i haven't run
the numbers uh
i've again just found out last night so
currently it stands i should be done by
february um of 2024 and that's without a
roommate without a side hustle what do
you what do you do for a living
i'm an executive assistant
okay how far are you from work
i am in my living room right now
oh so i get to work remotely okay so
it's remote yeah
yeah
you could do some extra virtual
assisting on the side if that's
something you want to do to get the
income up right now i would probably
also get a roommate if you're cool with
that for a year to speed up the process
because that's just a long time to
remain in baby step 2 and not knowing
what the market's going to do with rent
yeah agreed so you would sign then and
just continue to no no
no not yet i mean you've known about
this for 24 hours
so i'm going to um
how long will they give you to make your
decision
so i have until the 31st because it
needs to be a 60-day notice however if i
don't
um i have to do a 30-day notice from
that point onward uh well from may 31st
onward so you know hypothetically yeah i
i would say between now and the 31st you
have a new hobby and that's looking at
rentals
yeah
i mean you've scanned the market enough
to ascertain that this is not they're
not gigging you that this is just the
new price in the marketplace
you know they're they're not being
crooks or something like that they've
not done anything wrong
uh and and you don't have a lot of
options that are readily apparent but
that's 24 hours worth of research so
right you know i i really think i'm
gonna go looking for that garage
apartment out back of some rich old
lady's house or something that uh
you know that's 10 or 15 miles further
out
of your center of normal
behaviors
that's a little bit less convenient but
it's half the price i'm gonna look for
that needle in a haystack for a little
while i'm not gonna bet my life on it
but i mean boy if you could land
something back down around a thousand
dollars that was tolerable and was safe
and clean and that kind of stuff um if
it was a little bit inconvenient i'd
rather do that
uh but but you're not gonna find that in
the first 24 hours you know you're going
to spend some time and effort
to find that property if it even exists
i'm not saying it does a hundred percent
of the time but one of the things one of
my rules on decision making is when i
have two part possible options and both
of them suck
i don't yet have enough options
that's a fair plan okay
so i want to put more options on the
table even if they're
uncomfortable for other reasons
sure you know other than just price
uh the price is right but it's
uncomfortable because of dot dot dot and
i don't know what whether the dot dot
dot is
tolerable or not but after that i'm with
george yeah i pick up extra work and uh
take in a roommate and uh try to try to
find another way to get at this housing
angle and being remote i mean you could
move further out to a cheaper area easy
temporarily this is not forever but as
while you're getting out of date and get
that emergency fund in place
i mean i i'm the world's worst i mean we
just moved uh in october
for the first time i don't move much i
can't stand moving it's like having a
root canal but uh we moved uh about 20
minutes further
away from downtown nashville
we were already about 25 minutes out of
downtown nashville which i don't go down
there that much except to eat good food
scene in nashville uh but uh but now it
feels like like we're out in the country
we gotta get up we gotta get a list and
go to town you know it feels like oh my
god and it's not that much further no
it's five ten minutes but it feels like
fifteen minutes but it's just feels it's
there's an emotional adjustment more
than a factual
yeah adjustment yeah that's what i found
out with that too we moved to the
suburbs with all these families and
she's like i want to be near nashville
where all the action is and i can tell
well you know with a young lady like
that i don't want to be right down there
in a minute though i mean my point is
it's it's more mental than it is actual
yeah sometimes to be further out and it
might change the
price equation substantially 15 minutes
might say 500 bucks to be 10 minutes
further out depending on which direction
you went and so on that that kind of
thing there's a way to think about it
i'm i'm not saying that's the answer but
um here's a good thing to keep in mind
all of you that are facing rent uh
increases and real estate price
increases and everything else
the the you know one of the classes i
took getting my degree in real estate
was urban planning and generally
speaking uh with no barriers which never
exists
but with no political or geographical uh
or topographical barriers
if you take the downtown area of a the
central business district and you drop a
pebble there
the rings go out like in a pond
and the further out those rings you go
generally speaking it's cheaper now the
exceptions are when one of those rings
bumps into a piece of water
the price might go way up or one of
those rings bumps into a mountain the
price might go way up
and the other side of that mountain
might be way down because it's very
inconvenient to drive around it
or the other side of the bay tampa hello
you know that kind of a thing right so
there's
that that
ring theory breaks down when it bumps
into stuff yeah but generally the
further you go out into rule from the
central business district of a major
metroplex
the cheaper it gets generally now again
an exception will be political things
one of those is in nashville is the
county that we live in is out several
rings but it is the wealthiest county in
tennessee the 11th wealthiest county in
the nation
and so house prices here are bonkers oh
yeah
because of that but it's it's the quote
place to live so to speak that kind of
crap there's a new neighborhood across
from ours and the houses we're starting
it's all dirt still they were starting
at 700. i just checked back in they're
now 1.3 million dollars and it's still
dirt
but they just up the
they just changed the sign housing
beginning at yes prices beginning at
mark through it mark through it mark
through it and keep raising them yeah
you can but that's but again
the whole idea being that if you move
out a little bit further
i will admit because i'm experiencing it
personally that you have a bit of an
emotional hangover and that you
feel like that you're further out than
you really are it's not that big a deal
because people that are laughing all
around america right now they're hearing
me talk about a 15-minute commute like
it's a big deal uh because they're like
try two hours and 15 minutes on a train
playing automobiles exactly bus but but
the uh uh again
just to challenge you because you can
always when you're renting especially
you can always move out a little bit
because it's a temporary move renting is
always camping it's glorified camping
while we wait to get out of debt and
build up the money to buy a house
good discussion and boy it's a big thing
out there right now this rent it is
something else